ame un sistema global
en nuestras ciudades industrias fueron
saqueadas las comunidades comunidades
fueron devastadas las plantas de
manufactura fueron enviadas a china
eso es lo que sucede cuando washington
se detiene a ser y no es la capital de
eeuu sino es la capital del mundo
como un embajador en alemania si fui
testigo de la política exterior de
donald trump
pude ver como negociaba en nombre de los
estadounidenses vi como eso me encantaba
a la canciller alemana mientras insistía
que alemania debía pagar sus
obligaciones en la otan
estuve cuando trope le dijo
que estados unidos pague sus
obligaciones pero conmigo se detiene no
voy a dejar que la gente que paga
impuestos pague esto
- la administración de donald trump
siempre ha sido muy clara que nuestra
prioridad
es la seguridad del pueblo
estadounidense
ese es el trabajo de todos los líderes
poner a su pueblo primero si hemos visto
como estrategia ha tenido éxito en los
pocos cuatros años han logrado incluso
algunos demócratas estén de acuerdo en
la amenaza china
en las alianzas que van que tienen una
responsabilidad en cuatro años
trump no comenzó ni inició ninguna
guerra reconstruyó el ejército y firmó
acuerdos de paz que hicieron eeuu más a
salvo
y llaman a esta política nacionalismo
todo lo que necesitan saber
cuando los demócratas llama a trump
nacionalista creen que los insultan
como si el presidente de eeuu no debería
basarse en el interés de los propios
estadounidenses
los demócratas le dieron dinero al
gobierno tirano de irán miles de dólares
trump hizo una maniobra similar con un
avión pero era muy diferente a ésta
cuando aquellos que buscan la libertad
toman riesgo personal como en hong kong
terán o minsk no hay duda alguna words
cuál es el apoyo de la administración
trump equipo siempre vamos a estar con
la persona con las personas que luchen
por sus libertades
no se dejen engañar el establishment de
washington quiere venderles a su
candidato
joe biden fue elegido al senado en 1972
48 años atrás bueno es la típica
historia de washington
22 se lanzaron como candidatos
y eligieron esta mañana el último
que ya debería retirarse ofrece ofrece
una nueva idea pero por qué no pensó eso
en los últimos 4 48 años
hoy los demócratas culpan a la pandemia
creciente throne que empezó en china
y culpan en la fenómeno con rusia cuando
fue algo de hillary clinton
lo que vi por parte de los demócratas
me hizo enfermar la administración obama
biden lanzó una campaña secreta contra
trump y silencio aquellos que iban a
hablar en contra de eso me presentaron
información falsa mintieron a los jueces
y clasificaron todo lo que podría
perjudicarlos y luego que trump ganó la
elección cuando debían continuar con la
tradición de ayudar
presidente y en su transición a la casa
blanca lo que hicieron fue obstaculizar
lo aún más
el ex vicepresidente pidió ocultar
la información tres de tres semanas
antes de la inauguración de la nueva
administración
firme ellos no han querido que los
estadounidenses sepan quién tomar las
acciones pero control siempre van a
saber quién está a cargo porque la
respuesta es ustedes son ustedes los que
están a cargo de los intereses
personales y quienes apoyan a china ni
los fanáticos de la globalización con
donald trump y con pensé en la casa
blanca
el pueblo es el jefe
la política exterior de trump es estado
en eeuu primero y no en el interés de un
grupo sobre el interés de otro no es
sobre rojo o azul educados o no educados
eeuu primero es la creencia que los
políticos deben enfocarse en la igualdad
y dignidad de todos los estadounidenses
y que este deber debe hacerse con la
responsabilidad seguridad de todos
america first eso es eeuu primero esa es
la doctrina de trump y eso mis amigos es
4 años más
[Música]